over the last 15 years no one in WWE has
generated a more commanding and divisive
reaction from the WWE Universe that John
Cena in honor of the 15th anniversary of
one of the most iconic and polarizing
WWE superstars of all time who can
presents WWE 2k 18 seen enough edition
[Applause]
get the seen enough focus pack to play
as to a job Cena's top riders from his
WWE career Batista and Rob Van Dam
this bonus pack also includes two
playable versions of John Cena's as an
added bonus you'll receive Zakharchenko
pack featuring two playable versions of
WWE Hall of Fame superstar Kurt Angle
each special edition includes an acrylic
limited edition commemorative plaque
featuring an autograph from John Cena
and a piece of the Ring map for his
record-tying 16th Heavyweight
Championship win at Royal Rumble
thousand seventeen in addition you'll
receive an exclusive Mattel johncena
action figure featuring a reversible
t-shirt
gain access to even more bonus content
with the WWE 2k 18 season pass packed
with additional superstars movesets
and much more plus you'll get super
cardona's content featuring limited
edition cards featuring John Cena
Batista and Rob Van Dam supplies are
limited so pre-order now and celebrate
the extraordinary 15th anniversary of
the career of John Cena